maître adrien gabo merci d'être là vous
êtes l'avocat du jeune homme qui était
mis en examen pour le meurtre de
marjorie c'est vrai qu'on se dit comme
on est avocat
quels mots on va trouver pour défendre
un tel acte alors justement la question
il a faut-il abaisser la majorité pénale
à 14 à 15 ans puisqu'il a 14 ans le
laser
voilà le suspect on va dire suspect
encore voilà quelle mouche on peut
trouver
merci de votre invitation
d'abord vous m'avez interrogé comment
peut-on défendre un tel acte je ne
défends pas un acte je défends une
personne qui est suspecté de l'avoir
commis et disons le qu'il a commis et
c'est très différent
je suis avocat sur vous devriez pas dire
ça et par vieux ne défend évidemment pas
un acte je ne défends pas un crime
je ne glorifie pas un crime je défends
celui qu'il a commis c'est très
différent déjà intellectuellement
parlant
et puis je pars de l'idée qu'un criminel
quel qu'il soit ce soit cette affaire-là
une autre affaire n'est pas réductible
au crime qu'il a commis le crime qu'il a
commis est un moment déterminant dans sa
vie et dans la vie de la victime mais
qu' il n'est pas réductible à cet
instant là et puis enfin je crois que le
passage à l'acte le coup de couteau le
coup de fusil ou le passage à l'acte est
un moment de bascule qui a un certain
nombre de raisons d'explications pas d'
excuses d'explication c'est différent et
que les explications que l'on doit
donner sont importantes aussi pour la
victime
j'en veux pour la famille de la victime
mais bien sûr j'en veux pour preuve que
la première chose que dans le procès
d'arthur royer ou dans le procès de
daval les familles des victimes qu est
ce qu elles ont demandé en premier c'est
que l'accusé parle bien sûr il donne des
explications et donc la défense d'un
criminel consiste aussi à permettre
cette expression parce que c'est
important pour nous pour la justice pour
la société sans doute pour le criminel
mais également pour les victimes
et lorsque l'on met et lorsque l'on met
tout ça en perspective
vous voyez qu'on est dans un cadre très
différents que l'avocat qui défendrait
un acte c'est pas le cas alors maître
adrien gabon vous êtes donc je vous le
redis l'avocate du jeune homme qui a été
mis en examen pour le meurtre de
marjorie s'il regrette ce qui a fait
bien sûr qu'est ce qui dit il est très
au delà des regrets il est accablé de
remords il a des mots il se rend compte
de la gravité
il a brisé une vie qu'il a brisé une
famille qui l'a brisée mal à sa famille
c'est un maniaque salaire à l'abri ils
sont pas de lui il s'en rend compte
bien sûr qu'il s'en rend compte il est
incapable par exemple de manger ils
pleurent arsa normes et attendait un jeu
à la famille de marge du sommet est
arrivé leclerc n'ont pas parié sur lui
un jour mais il n'est pas gagnée chaque
homme n'est donc pas question passionne
à 2 le présent il ne se plaint pas je
dis simplement que pendant 48 heures il
est incapable de manger quoi que ce soit
parce qu'il est traumatisée par son acte
il reconnaît sa responsabilité
sa responsabilité est écrasante et à cet
égard il montre de la fecq il montre des
regrets mais qu'est ce qu'il faudrait il
faudrait qu'il soit froid et qu'il
n'exprime rien non mais bon donc le fait
sa faveur elle a réagi comment comment
sa famille j'ai rencontré ses parents et
ses parents sont dépassés ne m'apporte
pas d'explication rationnelle une
comprennent pas c'est un gamin qui n'a
jamais été violent qui n'a jamais été ce
qui s'est passé dans sa tête il vous dit
quoi s'est passé quoi c'est dû la
succession de plusieurs séquences qui
ont abouti
à cet acte il ya une surenchère d'abord
sur les réseaux sociaux en suit une
bagarre qui aboutit à cet acte
irréparable irrémédiable mais mon client
est bien entendu accablés de remords de
regrets ils les expriment devant les
policiers devant les juges
la famille de marjorie votre client non
encore non donc il n'explique pas son
geste il a pas d'explication si si bien
sûr lui cette fois son équipe il le fait
un récit répond aux questions les
policiers c'est très classique messieurs
vous le confirmera les policiers lui
pose un certain nombre de questions
précises à tel moment tels faits avec
qui comment et répond à toutes les
questions qui lui sont posées d'accord
oui qu'elle est tout à l'heure vous
parliez de circonstance actuellement
entre n'y avait pas de pardon bien sûr
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans la
vie de ce petit vous êtes bien capable
vous le côtoyer pour savoir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé quel a été le déclic et
quel est son passé pourquoi commettre un
acte comme ça il n'a pas de passé de
délinquant
il a un casier judiciaire vierge
heureusement il a 14 ans non mais jolie
oui un casier judiciaire vierge parce
que nous on nous l'a fait souvent celle
ci que les servir c'est un des gros
casier connu des services de police non
mais c'est pas dans ce bar et droit
alors allez me je voudrais bien
comprendre finalement ce que ce gamin a
fait vous n'êtes pas là pour le défendre
en voudrai juste comprendre sans doute
laissé répond quand même
une information précise il un casier
vierge c'est pas à charge ou à décharge
d'accord il assez puissamment factuel
mais si ça vous fait plaisir de dire que
peut-être il se serait pas le cas pas de
problème je dis que madame interroge sur
les raisons du passage à l'acte
je crois que ici nous tous dans la
société
ça peut intéresser les gens de
déterminer les raisons du passage à
l'acte parce que je pense à ces raisons
me semble-t-il ne sont pas allés
chercher dans un passé judiciaire
puisque précisément il n'existe pas ce
écologique alors donc est ce que il ya
des carences éducatives pour moi est ce
qu'il ya des difficultés scolaires ne
répond pas en gros le tajine et si je
réponds monsieur vous dit qu'il a un
casier judiciaire vierge moi je vous
dise qu'il est connu des services de
police avant ça lorsqu'il a commis des
petites infractions non plus non
inscrits plus hauts gradés et
judiciaires et puis très longtemps mais
encore une fois monsieur moi j'essaie de
le sauver ce gamin j'aurais bien voulu
sauver bien avant jeudi passé
aujourd'hui est bien sûr l'intérêt
répondra jamais quoi que j'avais commis
alors cessé de seconde
pas de casier pas d'antécédents vie est
bon ok vraiment de ma question la mairie
une bonne réputation et il est alors je
continue
oui maintenant voilà le volet judiciaire
le volet scolaire en troisième mais il
est donc collégiens il a des difficultés
en maths
il est plutôt bon en histoire géo et en
sport donc 14 en troisième
il n'y a pas d'anomalie scolaire il a
été renvoyé
quand il était en classe de sixième pour
des problèmes de comportement et
d'absentéisme mais c'est que ça ne le
oui mais bon ce soir va pas rentrer non
mais le truc 6 et je vais vous dire ce
qu'est ce qu'il a été influencé par son
sur son pour faire ou pas du tout par
les autres par des camarades pas du tout
non il a laissé un acte vraiment ici ni
là ni mais écoutez et convenez que
parfois ou en tout cas à l'heure où je
vous parle il n'y a pas d'explication
rationnelle
votre client a été mis en examen pour
meurtre pas pour assassinat donc pour le
moment la thèse de la préméditation
n'est pas retenue mais quand même il est
il est là il monte chez son père il va
chercher un couteau
il redescend avec le couteau in tu
marjorie donc dans sa tête il s'est dit
je vais aller chercher un couteau papa
va chercher un couteau
c'est pour frapper avec m ils voulaient
tuer vous avez raison il n'est pas mise
en examen pour assassinat donc la
préméditation n'a pas été retenue
il va chercher un couteau mais il va
également chercher son sac de sport pour
l'instant on va pas on va pas dans le
processus
voilà vous plaidez on essaie de
descendre le gamin vous plaidez vous
êtes mais je ne joue pas je l'y ai pas
d'expression